[Aplausos]
ha sido una de las carreras más
acaloradas y reñidas John federman
consiguió una victoria simbólica para
los demócratas en el estado clave de
Pensilvania
nunca esperé que fuéramos a convertir
estos condados rojos en azules pero
Hicimos lo que teníamos que hacer y
tuvimos esa conversación en todos estos
condados
una importante Victoria que hace unos
meses parecía impensable para este
hombre de 53 años tras sufrir un derrame
cerebral durante la campaña que lo hizo
sufrir en un debate contra el célebre
médico republicano memes of que contaba
con el respaldo de Donald Trump conocido
por sus tatuajes y sus sudaderas con
capucha Peter más alto por primera vez a
la atención nacional como alcalde de la
pequeña ciudad en el cinturón del óxido
estadounidense la defensa de la clase
trabajadora fue uno de los Pilares de su
campaña
Esta carrera es por el futuro de cada
comunidad de toda Pensilvania
por cada pueblo pequeño o persona que
alguna vez se haya sentido abandonada
por cada puesto de trabajo que se ha
perdido por cada fábrica que se ha
cerrado
abogando por la consagración del derecho
al aborto en la ley federal y apoyando
la legalización de la marihuana feterman
también se ha convertido en un icono
progresista sus puntos de vista
liberales y su lucha por los obreros
atrajeron a los votantes de Pensilvania
en lo que podría ser una victoria
crucial para los demócratas en un estado
bisagra
[Aplausos]